football the beautiful game  with an ugly administration at world  championship level  meps themselves this week kicked the  debate about the future of fifa around  calling for zero tolerance of corruption  and for an interim president  and one of the upcoming world cups in  russia and qatar  tarnished by allegations of corruption  and worker rights abuses the bids for  the 2018 and 2022 world cups  should be investigated and if there's  any evidence of wrongdoing  the entire process should be rerun  um  and the last word on behalf of the fans  the billions who feel  mightily let down too i go to football  every week and ordinary fans are  disgusted by fifa  the whole organization needs to be  dismantled  and reassembled from the beginning from  first principles  meps also underlined the importance of  the fbi and swiss investigations  currently underway  and called for eu states to boost joint  investigations to tackle any corruption  committed in the eu